[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce set
8 sport sur tv 60,18 l'émission à ne pas
manquer si vous êtes un passionné de
sport local c'est parti pour le sommaire
golfe
invité exceptionnel dans ce set 8 sport
nous aurons avec nous dans cette
émission le directeur technique national
christophe muniesa ans en nous parlerons
des golfeurs professionnels évinois du
tournoi lindsay rope nfl golf
programmées cette semaine au golf
national jo-2000 24 focus sur la colline
d'elancourt le lieu qui va accueillir
les épreuves de vtt
le projet avance le 31 mars dernier
regroupement de cinq entreprises a été
chargé d'aménager les 231 mètres du site
reportage à suivre course à pied le
paris versailles 2021 programmée en
septembre mais officiellement annulé les
organisateurs ont préféré limiter les
risques par rapport à la crise sanitaire
et de sart seront donc remboursés
interview dans ce magazine l'actualité
sportive c'est maintenant sur tv 78
mais avant de développer ces titres nous
allons parler à des confinement dans le
monde du sport peu de changements ce 3
mai seule la levée de la restriction des
10 km peut permettre de faire du sport
un peu plus loin de chez soi
il ya également le retour du sport
scolaire en équipements intérieurs en
revanche ça s'accélère à partir du 19
mai il y aura à la réouverture des
piscines municipales et lors autour du
public dans les stades avec des jauges
de 800 personnes en intérieur et émile
en extérieur enfin le 9 juin il y aura
la réouverture des salles de sport après
huit mois d'arrêt la reprise du sport
sans contact en intérieur et la reprise
des sports avec du contact en extérieur
la jauge pour les spectateurs sera de
5000 dans les enceintes sportives
le retour à la normale est lui prévu le
30 juin tout cela est évidemment
conditionné à l'évolution de la crise
sanitaire
on continue par du tennis arthur
rinderknecht continue à monter en
puissance à la proche de roland garros
l'ebit noah originaire de saint germain
en laye a réussi à atteindre les demi
finales du tournoi challenger d'ostrava
en république tchèque tête de série
numéro 4 libinois dû abandonner contre
l'argentin renshaw olivier suite à une
douleur à la jambe alors qu'il perdait 5
4 dans le premier set par précaution
arthur rinderknecht ne disputera pas le
tournoi de prague
cette semaine petite consolation et
décroche ce lundi la 124e place mondiale
son meilleur classement dans sa carrière
il est toujours le numéro 2 français à
l'arrêt c'est devrait être à roland
garros on continue à part du golf l'un
des meilleurs français du moment antoine
or other n'a pas réalisé le meilleur
tournoi de sa carrière au tenerife open
en espagne les blinois qui s'entraîne au
golf de la boulie à versailles a raté le
cut et termine trois coups au-dessus du
par antoine ros nord pourra se relancer
cette semaine il sera présent comme tête
d'affiché dans les yvelines au golf
national de saint quentin en yvelines
pour le mixer à open
ff golf le rendez vous est organisé de
jeudi à samedi à huis clos à cause de la
crise sanitaire
nous allons maintenant prendre la
direction de saint nom la bretèche la
ville abrite un golf d'exception le
parcours a été jouée par des stars de la
discipline les greens ont également reçu
des compétitions internationales dont le
célèbre taureau faits allant comme un
montage de rémi lefebvre
[Musique]
un golf mondialement connue au coeur des
yvelines le golf de saint nom la
bretèche a été officiellement inaugurée
en 1959
le complexe a été construit autour de
cette ferme du xviiie siècle sur
d'anciennes terres agricoles de la
plaine de versailles
la structure a été fondé par daniel féau
le projet de sa vie c'est un golf
immobilier c'est à dire que le principe
était de vendre des maisons puisque
aujourd'hui vous avez autour du golf 110
maisons qui sont des propriétaires et
donc c'est ta gueule films oubliés où
les gens avaient leur résidence
secondaire à cette époque là
très vite le parcours accueille de
grandes compétitions saint nom la
bretèche reçoit trois reprises l'open de
france de golf deux événements montrent
également fait la renommée du site la
canada cup en 1963 un championnat du
monde professionnel par équipes
mais c'est surtout le trophée lancôme
qui propulse le site dans une nouvelle
dimension de 1970 à 2003 le rendez-vous
a été organisé à 34 reprises sur le golf
évinois et a permis d'attirer les plus
grands celle qui nous a été pour lequel
on avait le plus d'infections s'était
ballesteros parce que parce qu'il ya des
images qui ont énormément ce recul est
notamment entre numéro 15 où il a fait
un coup à genoux donc on s'attache
forcément des gens comme ça mais toutes
les personnes sont venus et ont commencé
au début d'une en cours avec avec palmer
avec player avec floyd
enfin toutes les générations se passer
ici c'était vraiment on a commencé avec
le premier lancôme qui étaient les huit
meilleurs joueurs mondiaux
la seule personne qu'on ait raté à cause
des attentats c'est tiger woods qui
était prévu
malheureusement cette année là le
tournoi n'a pas eu lieu pour répondre
aux exigences du haut niveau et des 1000
membres de la structure le parcours de
style anglo saxons comprend 2 18 trous
de 6300 m avec des greens considérés
comme les plus rapides de france par les
spécialistes au total 21 jardiniers sont
présents sur le site pour permettre à
saint-nom-la-bretèche de conserver ses
standards aujourd'hui et ça continue ce
sont des greens en sable ce sont des
greens naturellement aux normes usagers
c'est un parcours aujourd'hui qui s
appelait régulièrement on a des
contraintes qualitative qui sont faites
par les rendez-vous qu'on a et qui nous
oblige à être à la hauteur des
événements
une nouvelle compétition d'envergure
sera programmée en 2022 sur le parcours
saint nom la bretèche organisera les
championnats du monde amateurs par
équipes du 25 août au 4 septembre
les compétitions que le parcours qu
organisera avec le golf national de
saint quentin en yvelines
nous allons continuer à parler de golf
et plus précisément de golf et binoy le
directeur technique national de la
fédération française christophe monier
êtes avec nous via écran interposé pour
nous parler de ce golf heavy noir
bonsoir bonsoir mikhalev bonsoir à tous
alors par les boeufs avec vous ce soir
alors tout d'abord on va parler du golf
2 à saint nom la bretèche qu'est ce que
vous en pensez de ce golf à votre sujet
a bien résumé la particularité de ce
love
certes à l'origine un projet foncier
antoine fait en le directeur du golf l'a
parfaitement expliqué mais c'est au delà
de ça un fantastique stade de gaulle qui
a accueilli de nombreux tournois le long
au bien sûr les championnats du monde en
2022 vous l'avez évoqué et c'est pas
forcément ce qui vient spontanément à
l'esprit quand on pense à saint nom la
bretèche
on pense vieilles pierres résidence
foncière des belles pièces d'eau mais
c'est surtout un véritable défi sportif
golfique pour les champions du monde
entier qui sont venus battre le faire et
ils reviendront puisque ça fait partie
véritablement de l'histoire de ce club
donc un haut lieu du sport français
alors il ya énormément de golf 1 dans
les yvelines c'est l'un des départements
où il ya le plus de golf notamment
comment fait pour se démarquer là on
voit que ça dans la bretèche penche sur
la compétition avant tout ouais il ya
différentes composantes dans l'activité
golfique en france mais c'est le cas
aussi dans d'autres pays on pose bien
sûr au verso du golfe côté de l'europe
en tout cas la grande bretagne il ya
cette dimension sportive l'accueil des
grands événements qui contribue à la
notoriété des golfs français et plus
particulièrement des golfs yvelinois
vous avez raison de le souligner les
yvelines c'est 30 parcours et c'est le
département le plus golfique de france
c'est trente mille licenciés et on y
accueille des dizaines de milliers de
touristes golfeurs
chaque année donc il ya une dimension
sportive il ya aussi l'attractivité
touristique
et puis
google dont les yvelines s'inscrit aussi
parfaitement dans le patrimoine on va
dire du département le patrimoine
régional même la proximité bien sûr de
versailles et puis la complémentarité
aussi avec des équipements bien sûr on
pense au golf national
on peut penser à des équipements aussi
mythiques tels que le golf du racing
club de france ou encore le goal de
saint germain donc une véritable
richesse et une grande diversité aussi
des parcours franciliens alors on va
revenir sur l'actualité sportive du
moment il ya un golfeur qui performent
assez bien en ce moment c'est antoine
runner le pensionnaire du golf de la
boulie justement à versailles il a
notamment battu brian deux chambres aux
états unis dans un match à un contre un
il a également remporté à deux titres
sur l'european tour que pensez-vous
d'antoine runner c'est l'archétype du
joueur français moderne qui est capable
de performer sur tous les continents ont
disons le comme ça il fait jeu égal là
sur ces derniers mois avec l'actuel
grand français victor perez vous l'avez
souligné deux victoires en six mois sur
les européennes tout ce n'est pas rien
une victoire aussi dans une épreuve de
championnat du monde l'acte s'est
imposée entre barisone de chambre au
même si malheureusement après antoine
aller plus loin dans le tournoi
il est particulièrement en forme un jeu
très puissant il a été formé bien sûr au
racing club de france mais aussi aux
états unis puisqu'il y a passé quatre
ans dans les os collège
il a aussi joué en équipe de france ça a
été un des piliers les équipes de france
amateur avant de passer pro bref ils
cochent toutes les cases antoine pour
s'imposer au plus haut niveau mondial
et c'est évidemment tout ce qu'on laisse
que tout ce qu'on lui souhaite pas
redondant les moines vous misé beaucoup
sur lui à la fédé oui oui bien sûr alors
en toi
on va oublier sur le bord de la route
parce qu'il ya d'autres joueurs aussi
très talentueux et qui sont plutôt le
vent en poupe on sait à des joueurs
comme romain langue à ce que par exemple
mais indéniablement ce que fait antoine
heureuse nerfs depuis quelques mois est
tout simplement impressionnant et puis
je l'évoquais de par la puissance qui
développe son mental aussi sa capacité à
s'imposer quand il est dans le coup
c'est très bien d'enchaîner les places
d'honneur et c'est évidemment pour
s'imposer au plus haut niveau aussi
remporté les victoires c'est ce que
c'est ce qui est capable de faire en toi
donc oui indéniablement ils vont parmi
les français qui affiche le plus gros
potentiel pour continuer de grimper dans
la hiérarchie ming est ce que vous voyez
un jour peut-être décrocher une place à
la ryder cup
oui alors sur l'île là aussi il en a
clairement le potentiel et le profil
aujourd'hui il est très bien classé 1
sur le classement européen
on va pas encore vendre la peau de
l'ours mais savez il ya évidemment le
golf est présent jeux olympiques à tokyo
cet été antoine aujourd'hui serait
valeur aujourd'hui le deuxième français
qualifiés aux côtés de victor perez pour
représenter et les couleurs tricolores à
tokyo donc oui on lui promet bien sûr un
grand avenir en sport après ans et c'est
une chose d'afficher un potentiel on est
une autre de le réaliser mais la
progression d'antoine au cours de ces
derniers mois est tout simplement une
figurante donc
il affiche raisonnable ambitions pour
ces tournois
bien évidemment il ya aussi des joueuses
féminines 1 qui performent des joueuses
féminines yvelinoise un bien sûr je
parle notamment de charlotte liothier de
saint nom la bretèche qui a gagné en
italie ou encore manon giga lee qui a
gagné en afrique du sud récemment
qu'est ce que vous pensez de ces
victoires là aussi elles sont de bon
augure pour le golf yvelinois bien sûr
mais au-delà de ça pour le golf français
les joueurs qui les joueuses pardon qui
sont actuellement à la tête en tête du
classement national
réponse est assez dynamique et qui
évolue sur le circuit américain
également perrine delacour est très
clairement que ce soit charlotte uk ou
manon giga lee elles sont aujourd'hui en
pleine phase de progression
manon est quant à elle déjà joueuse
professionnelle et cette victoire en
afrique du sud ça a été dans sur les
dents les remparts mon professionnels
pour charlotte est encore jeune amateur
elle va passer pro très
vraisemblablement à la fin de l'année et
là aussi elles en pleine progression
elle affiche un solide potentiel
c'est très très bonne augure c'est de
josé pour le boeuf
alors on retrouvera toutes ces pépites
évinoise cette semaine au lycée open ff
golfe qui s'organise et de jeudi à
samedi au golf national de saint quentin
en yvelines
ce tournoi se dispute du coup sur 54
trous il sent que tu
il va permettre à une soixantaine de
joueurs et joueuses professionnelles et
une trentaine d'amateurs de s'affronter
quel est l'objectif de ce type de
tournoi il ya une particularité dans la
période que nous traversons certaines
épreuves sportives sont autorisés c'est
le cas des tournois professionnels et
des tournois qui sont réservées aux
sportifs de haut niveau inscrit sur
liste est en revanche pour l'ensemble
des sportifs amateurs bien la saison est
suspendu on espère bien évidemment et on
assez confiant sur ce sujet que ces
épreuves amateurs vont pouvoir reprendre
à compter du 19 mai mais en tout état de
cause
actuellement ce n'est pas le cas donc ce
qu on a souhaité faire
et grâce un lycée à vos efforts la
fédération et des acteurs du golfe
franciliens on a pu réussir à programmer
cette épreuve
on a saisi cette opportunité suite au
report de l'open de france il date s'est
libérée dans le calendrier
donc on a sauté sur l'occasion organiser
cette épreuve mixte
donc il y aura des joueuses et des
joueurs
il y aura aussi des joueurs amateurs et
professionnels qui vont pouvoir
s'affronter au golf national
donc l'idée était de permettre à cette
catégorie de joueurs de rester chaud on
va dire et de se préparer dès que la
saison va pouvoir battre son plein d'ici
quelques semaines
donc c'est une épreuve qui se situe un
peu dans l'antichambre des épreuves de
haut niveau traditionnel qui peuplent le
calendrier international et on voulait
donner cette opportunité aux joueurs et
joueuses français est bien de continuer
à se préparer dans les meilleures
conditions sur un parcours qui aurait
été préparée lui spécialement pour
l'occasion qui sera extrêmement
compétitif ça sera un véritable
challenge sportif
on a hâte d'y retrouver les meilleurs
amateurs et professionnels français
cette semaine au golf national dans les
immeubles dernière question et ce très
rapidement est ce que vous avez une
d'actes reprogrammé pour l'open de
france de golf ou pas encore pour ce qui
est du calendrier 2021 nous n'avons pas
identifié avec l'oeil européenne tour au
moment où on parle de date pour cette
édition 2021 on y travaille on y croit
pour autant en revanche pour ce qui est
de 2022
on travaille sur une hypothèse qui
consisterait à ce que le tournoi sera
organisé à la fin du mois de septembre
2022 ce qui serait une très bonne date
pour l'épreuve et qui nous permettrait
d'attirer de nombreux joueurs
internationaux
merci à vous christophe muniesa on
espère revoir l'open de france le plus
rapidement possible sur les greens du
golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines en continuelle
par dieu merci au revoir on continue par
du volley ball le club du nord du
département conflans andresy jouy et
race est assuré de terminer sur le
podium en fin de saison du championnat
élite les yvelinois sont pour l'instant
troisième à un match de la fin du
championnat derrière avignon et harnes
mais le club ne montera pas cette saison
le club pourrait plutôt tenter cette
aventure l'année prochaine nous aurons
d'ailleurs le président philippe miauton
doigt lundi prochain dans ce set 8 sport
en tumbling axel duriez des
clayes-sous-bois a brillé le double
champion du monde chez les à 13 14 ans a
réussi à se hisser jusqu'en finale des
championnats d'europe à sotchi en russie
mais les vinoy finalement perdu en
finale de l'épreuve le français s'est
incliné contre le russe dimitry chatalov
l'un des favoris de ce rendez vous le
sportif du 78 repart tout de même avec
une très belle médaille d'argent pour sa
première finale européenne
en basket victor webb anyama n'en finit
plus de surprendre à 17 ans seulement
l'illinois passer par le
chesnay-versailles réussi une grande
performance face à gravelines dunkerque
pour sa première titularisation en
première division dans le 5 de nanterre
celui que l'on surnomme le mutant a
contribué à la belle victoire des
joueurs des hauts-de-seine 102 à 81
le tout avec une bien jolie ligne
statistique 9 points 10 rebonds et 3
comptant 15 minutes de jeu seulement
le sportif de deux mètres 19 a une
nouvelle fois attiré les regards des
recruteurs de la nba enfin maintenant
prend la direction d'elancourt vous le
savez la colline a été sélectionnée pour
accueillir les épreuves de vtt lors des
jeux olympiques de 2024 et le projet
avance le 31 mars dernier la société de
livraison des ouvrages olympique soli
deo a désigné un regroupement de cinq
entreprises qui seront chargés
d'aménager cette colline des ans pour un
reportage de joe à sakal c'est une
nouvelle étape pour la colline
d'elancourt la solide et aux maîtres
d'ouvragé du projet a choisi cinq
entreprises pour aménager le futur site
qui accueillera les épreuves de vtt des
jeux olympiques de paris 2024 nous avons
beaucoup avancé entre autres avec
l'architecte spécialisés pour la
création des pistes d'un point de vue
sportif c'est à dire que le tracé des
pistes est arrêté je dis bien des pistes
à dire de la piste de paris 2024
elle-même mais également des pistes
secondaires annexes qui seront ouverts
au grand public une fois que les jeux
olympiques seront passées et puis nous
travaillons aujourd'hui je dis bien que
nous travaillons toujours avec la soli
deo sur les projets d'aménagement dit
lyon d'euros d'investissements sont
prévus pour le projet sans constructions
en dur sur le site et avec une portée
écologique pour que de futures familles
sportifs amateurs et promeneurs puissent
s'y balader nous pensons les
aménagements pour ce que l'on appelle
l'héritage c'est à dire rendre encore
plus vert et pérenne l'ensemble de tout
ce que vous voyez plantés sur ce site
avec un point culminant à 2 131 mètres
d'altitude
les élus locaux espèrent voir en ce
nouveau lieu un vrai emblème de réussite
de ces jo 2024 il sera ouvert et
accessible sachant qu'aujourd'hui
certes la colline est ouverte mais elle
est difficilement accessible il ya des
chemins qui sont même je dirais de
dangereux par moment puisque il s'est
quand même assez pentue c'est compliqué
d'y monter et de l'esthétique n'aura
rien à voir avec ce que c'est
aujourd'hui ça demeurera bien entendu le
point le plus haut d'île de france je
vous rappelle que du sommet de la
colline on voit la tour eiffel et envoie
tout paris mais ça sera également
certainement le point le plus
écologiquement respecté qui aura un vrai
bénéfice à la venue des jeux olympiques
de paris 2024 pas de date précise pour
les premiers coups de pioche mais en
attendant le département travaille déjà
sur les dispositifs de caméras pour une
meilleure retransmission possible on va
maintenant parler de course à pied alors
qu'elle était programmée à fin septembre
la course paris versailles vient d'être
annulée pour la deuxième année
consécutive à cause de la crise
sanitaire pour nous parler de cette
annulation nous avons avec nous et
manuel feillard directeur de la course
paris versailles et henri but serait un
coureur habitué à courir sur ce paris
versailles
il en a fait une vingtaine au total
bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir
alors pourquoi avoir décidé d'annuler ce
paris versailles 2021 emmanuel alors
tout d'abord on souhaite remercier
longtemps des des personnes qui nous ont
envoyé des messages de soutien la
semaine dernière est également merci à
l'ensemble de vos partenaires
institutionnels et privés qui nous ont
exprimé leur leur plein soutien
depuis la semaine dernière tout d'abord
paris versailles c'est une grosse
machine 25000 personnes au départ et
2500 intervenant pour faire fonctionner
l'organisation dont 1800 bénévoles
c'est quasiment 12 mois de travail pour
assurer les images que vous voyez
actuellement et donc
on a travaillé à une compression au
maximum du planning d'organisation sur 4
5 mois sachant que la période estivale
est pas toujours et dante pour contacter
l'ensemble de nos prestataires et
avancer sur l'organisation et on s'était
fixé donc la période de fin avril pour
décider de lancer ou pas l'organisation
donc ça c'était le le timing en ce
moment et comme vous le savez les
incertitudes sur les contraintes
sanitaires pour les prochains mois sont
sont très très fortes et ce malgré la
vaccination qui a été lancé depuis le
début de l'année par par la france
donc voilà la situation est le point le
plus important est le point financier
qui en faisant pour être totalement
transparent beaucoup de plans de
scénarios financiers nous aller nous
nous enjoindre est un déficit financier
très important qui allait forcément au
béret l'association et la pérennité de
paris versailles
donc c'est pourquoi on a décidé de ne
pas lancer l'organisation lundi dernier
comment la communiquer on est
parfaitement conscient de la déception
des coureurs et des coureuses qui pour
certaines d'entre elles sont des amours
et des amoureux ce prix versailles mais
on a pris la meilleure décision qui
était à date pour le bien de paris
versailles de son futur justement henry
but serez vous êtes un habitué à vous de
ce paris versailles est ce que vous êtes
très déçu sainte louise les jeux courts
depuis 93
une vingtaine de fois en tant qu'amateur
du dimanche uniquement pour ça et c'est
vrai que j'ai une réaction assez vive
quand j'ai vu le mais l'arrivée parce
que j'étais effectivement déçu déçu
parce que c'est une fête pour moi
convivial c'est une fête de copains une
fête de famille est là of hell passer à
la trappe
il y a également beaucoup d'étrangers
sur cette compétition
est-ce que ça a joué emmanuel fait hier
non pas du tout en règle générale on
accueille on aime le dire en arrière 300
à 400 court imprécis lien qui viennent
chaque année sur le paris versailles
mais et découverte du pouvoir écran j'ai
dit peu allemagne angleterre etc
mais c'est pas forcément la levée des
corps étrangers qui sont environ à 5 %
de la population de de paris versailles
qui représente le plus grand danger pour
nous c'est une ancienne des incertitudes
sanitaires et lancé une organisation qui
est qu'ils allaient générer un déficit
que ne peut pas supporter l'association
paris à versailles clairement donc non
les les corps étrangers ne sont pas du
tout du tout une raison qui nous a
poussé à cette décision
on parle beaucoup de passes sanitaire
également est ce que ça aurait pu
s'appliquer éventuellement emmanuel sur
ce type de rendez vous pourquoi pas on
le sent bien pour les événements d'été
avec les festivals de musique que le
plat sanitaires pour est une des
solutions
on attend de voir les décisions des
autorités ce qui nous soit ce qui nous
serait agréable c'est avoir une vision
très claire pour septembre avec les
régles du jeu de passes que l' on est
dans le sport aussi donc si on a des
règles du jeu ça fonctionne beaucoup
mieux et aujourd'hui c'est vrai que les
incertitudes nous nous font dire que
voilà c'est très compliqué à organiser
c'est une grosse machine et on aimerait
bien avoir des visions très précise ou
des règles très précises de la part des
autorités ça nous aiderait fortement
mais en tout cas on sait gérer 25
certificats médicaux donc des spas
sanitaires s'il le faut on le fera henry
la compétition est reporté à l'année
prochaine
est ce que vous serez quand même présent
en 2022 ça ne vous a pas découragé à
rassurer nous n'en aurons pas du tout
pas du tout évidemment c'était la
déception devenait aussi du fait que ça
montrait que le monde d'avant n'allait
pas revenir en septembre 2021
malheureusement et je pense que c'est
une très grosse déception un peu
naïvement de la part je pensais que tout
allait reprendre mais bien sûr en 22
mois je serai là avec les copains et la
famille vous allez vous entraîner un
petit peu d'ici là mais bien sûr des
ders convoi
on s'entraîne on voit qu'il ya beaucoup
de gens qui s'entraîne comme moi ou vélo
au bois partout on n'attend qu'une chose
c'est de pouvoir à nouveau courir
légèrement ensemble est-ce que vous
pouvez nous assuré emmanuel que la
course aura lieu en 2022 ou pareil il
faudra voir les conditions sanitaires du
moment j'espère que le 25 septembre 2000
22 ans on sera à chute ou sur la ligne
de départ notamment monsieur pucerie et
ses amis mais qui aujourd'hui est
capable d'avoir une vision sur 2000 2022
j'aimerais bien rencontrer cette
personne et nous rassurer que un certain
retour à la normale sera prévue le plus
rapidement possible mais en tout cas on
va y travailler comme on sera à vos
côtés de de tv fil 78 pour pour vous
informer sur la tenue de l'événement
merci à vous d'être intervenu dans cette
émission on souhaite que le paris
versailles et lieu le 25 septembre 2022
était vaisseau 118 sera bien sûr présent
pour cet événement on termine par un
rendez vous football c'est le match à
noter dans vos agendas ce mardi le paris
saint germain joue sa survie en ligue
des champions après leur défaite 2 1
contre city au match aller les joueurs
parisiens qui s'entraîne au camp des
loges de saint germain les se rendent à
manchester ce mardi dans l'espoir
d'inverser le score du match aller pour
se qualifier pour la finale de la
compétition
pour cela ils devront marquer au moins
deux buts sans en encaisser
la rencontre est programmée ce mardi à
21h
c'est la fin de cette émission merci
l'avoir suivi à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]